captain quite rightly didn't trust me to
really cook up emotion on the go I was
very inexperienced young actress I'm
certainly very emotional but he was
determined to get the best out of me so
he played a trick on me was the only one
he did during the film and it was with
it he asked me to come into his trailer
and he said let's just go over the words
for the scene I don't want any emotion
it was really wicked don't would any
emotion I don't want anything just say
the words so I said the words and he
said well what is that I mean you can't
do it like that and Herrera I of course
started to cry he pushed me onto the set
we did the scene it worked very naughty
but I thank him for it
wherever you are Charlie but I gathered
that
um it's dude adored his mother that he
had brought her over from England that
by that time she was mentally very
unstable uh but that in some way I think
the part that I played derasa was an
amalgam of his mother and of his wife
Oona and the clothes he wanted me to
wear were very specific he would say my
mother had a shawl my mother wore a
shawl like that or my mother had a
jacket like that and I realized that he
was recreating his mother in me um which
was very touching I have nothing more to
say about it that that's a fact that his
mother because the girl is is so wounded
in the first part of the film and he
brings her back to life I think that's
what he would very much like to have
been able to do but alas could not with
his mother
I always remember Oona when she was
asked in her or Chaplin's later years
and her middle years
about their marriage and she said well
when I was young he took care of me and
now I take care of him and I think
that's very much the story of limelight
and of youth and age are coming together
the impossibility really of it being
complete because it's so clear that one
of them is going to die will be for the
other and that the young girl has a life
with this young man do but it was it was
certainly as a salute to Onan and quite
honestly I think one of the reasons I
got it was that I looked so like ona at
that time that we were often mistaken
for each other it was a very all
together a very strange I mean if I
believed in fate and I suppose I do
it was absolutely fated that that I that
I played it I mean he was a genius and
it's very clear that he was in the film
and also I think Norman will agree the
film is very much but so personal to
Charlie that you will feel closer to him
and maybe that is why young people like
it and I'm very glad they do I think
it's wonderful that they do you will
feel closer to Charlie the man seeing
this film then in any of the other films
where he plays a character magnificently
but it this is different this is him
this film this great great masterpiece
which you'll see tonight was the
McCarthy area era
and J Edgar Hoover etc tried to stifle
this great film did not allow it to be
shown in many many cities I think here I
think Los Angeles was one was shown
quite late here
I just want to remind you that it's the
60th anniversary of this great
masterpiece and nobody was able to
stifle Chaplin you know
you